اوكرانيا. المجلس الاوروبي يتعهد
بالمساهمة باعادة اوكرانيا.
النمساوي لن ندفع ثمن الواردات
النفطية الروسية بالروبيل. وزير
تباين حاد في الموقف الاوروبي
حيث ان الجدل داخل الاتحاد
القضية? الاحداث والتطورات.
باريس ستجمد اربعة وعشرين مليار
على جثث جديدة لمدنيين اوكران في
ضواحي المدينة. رئيس وزراء
تحل هذه المشكلة ويتم انتزاع
الشوكة ام تستمر ايران في تعكير
منشأة عسكرية اوكرانية خلال اربع
وعشرين ساعة. تقارير تفيد بان
بايدن سيبحث خلال رحلته الى اسيا
كيفية محاسبة روسيا بسبب حربها
الاستخبارات الامريكية. الصحيفة
اكدت ان امريكا وفرت معلومات
جاء بعد انتشار خبر وجود عميل
لروسيا في ازوفستال كشف لهم
دولة كانت. القوات الروسية تعلن
ان سلاح الجو استهدف ثلاث وتسعين
دولار من ممتلكات اصدقاء بوتين
في فرنسا بلا روسيا يقول على
الامريكي جاوب يدرس اجراءات
معاقبة ايران ومنعها من امتلاك
الزيادة السريعة في امدادات
الاسلحة في وقت غيرت القوات
وباعترافهم. عندها خرج وزير
الخارجية الاوكراني ديمترو
ازواجستال بينما يموت المتحصنون
في المصنع من الجوع والامراض
المتحصنين في ازوفستال الى
الاستسلام مؤكدا استعداد قواته
اقتحام المصنع وفتح ممرات
انسانية لاجلاء المدنيين. كل ذلك
اتمام الاتفاق النووي في فيينا.
ادارة بايدن في مأزق بين ارضاء
لن تعيق روسيا عن تحقيق اهدافها.
لكن ماذا لو تأكد هذا الخبر هل
بينما دعت هناك كتيبة المجتمع
الدولي لاجلاء المدنيين والجنود
فاستغلوا ذلك. استغلوه فالجيش
سيتحرك حتى لو لم يرد بوتين ذلك.
من المجمع. تباين اوروبي. حظر
النفط الروسي بين موافق ومعارض
تندلع الحرب بين طن وموسكو وضع
ازوفستال. بوتين يدعو المقاتلين
القومي الامريكي وصف خبر الصحيفة
بغير المسئول بينما اكد الكرملين
مخابراتية ساعدت الاوكرانيين على
قتل الجنرالات وشملت المعلومات
بولندا ماتيوزمو راوسكي جمعنا
اكثر من ستة مليارات دولار لدعم
لقلة الغذاء والدواء ليخرج
الرئيس الاوكراني الزلانسكي
الاوروبي بشأن حظر النفط الروسي
ومشتقاته بسبب تحفظات واعتراض
اوكرانيا تطلب من امريكا مضادة
للسفن على وجه السرعة لتأمين
ويدعو الى هدنة مطولة لتأمين
اجلاء المدنيين من ماريوبول.
استخبارات قاتلة. صحيفة
النيويورك تايمز الامريكية تقول
لخروج امن للمدنيين المحاصرين مع
تأكيد مسبق من الكرملين بعدم
السراديب. قبل ذلك كانت موسكو قد
اعلنت وقف اطلاق النار في
ان اثني عشر جنرالا روسيا قتلتهم
القوات الاوكرانية بمساعدة
لكنها ظلت على ابواب المصنع في
ظل عدم الوصول الى بقية
بانها ستتخذ اجراءات عسكرية
حازمة ضد توسع الناتو على
ضربات مدفعية اسفرت عن مقتل
الضباط الروس لكن مجلس الامن
بريطانيا؟ اجراء خطير. مع اعلان
السويد عن تكرار الاستفزاز
انسحاب القوات من هجومها الفاشل
حول كييف لتركيز العمليات على
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني بوريس
جونسون ونظيره الياباني عن
بالمحيطين الهندي والهادئ.
بريطانيا واليابان يريدان اخذ
اليابان وبريطانيا تحالف جديد قد
يغير فرضيات الازمة الحالية
الاتفاق الذي يسمح للقوات
اليابانية والبريطانية بان تعمل
باسلحة بعيدة المدى حسب
الجارديان البريطانية تأتي
المناطق الشرقية والجنوبية من
اوكرانيا. السلاح البريطاني قد
الروسية فيه تكتيكاتها منذ
المرحلة الاولى من الحرب قبل
الخطوات الاستباقية قبل ان تقوم
كوريا الشمالية او الصين باي عمل
اليابانية فرض حزمة اضافية من
العقوبات على روسيا على خلفية
مع المملكة المتحدة. هنا قد
يتدخل مجنون كوريا الشمالية ويضع
اتفاق دفاعي بينهما في منطقة
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ وفق ما
وبريطانيا تدعم اوكرانيا بسلاح
قد يتسبب بكارثة ويطال المدن
اليابان تغضب بوتين بعقوبات
جديدة وتغازل بريطانيا عسكريا.
ايران وفرنسا تجمد اربعة وعشرين
مليار دولار على موسكو فكيف سيرد
الارجح لا يريد فلاديمير بوتين
مواجهة علنية مع حلف الناتو
صفو الامريكان.
اسرائيل او ازالة الحرس الثوري
الايراني من لائحة الارهاب للمضي
ولتوانيا الدولتين العضوتين في
الاتحاد الاوروبي. اجرى الجيش
الجيب الروسي المطل على بحر
البلطيق والواقع بين بولندا
الباليستية المتنقلة على حمل
رؤوس نووية. وزير الخارجية
كوليبا وقال ان دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي التي سترفض مقترح حظر
اسرار المصنع والسراديب التي بها
الاوكران بعدها بدأت الاشتباكات
في موعد عيد النصر الروسي على
النازية. شرطة كييب تعلن العثور
في الاتفاق النووي. وخلال كل هذا
تعلن واشنطن استعدادها لكافة
السيناريوهات للتعامل مع ايران
بشأن النووي. فكيف ستنتهي هذه
النفط الروسي ستكون متواطئة في
جرائم حرب. مأزق بايدن. الرئيس
بدوره ان المعلومات
الاستخباراتية المقدمة لاوكرانيا
مرارا وتكرارا من انضمام السويد
وفنلندا الى حلف الناتو وقالت
بهدف التخويف السويد ستتخذ موقفا
دبلوماسيا حيال هذا التصرف غير
لكن والى هذه اللحظة لم يتم
ارسال الاسلحة فهل تفعلها
يصل بتأثيره الى مدن روسية كونه
بعيد المدى بحسب خبراء عسكريين.
عسكري. فهل تنجحان في مساعيهما?
سلاح بريطاني في اوكرانيا. اعلنت
الحكومة البريطانية انها تبحث
امكانية تزويد الجيش الاوكراني
وتتحركا معا وبالتالي تعزيز
التزام المملكة المتحدة
تضمن بيان لدونيس فريت. ووفق
البيان فان من المقرر ان يعلن
الاحداث المرتبطة باوكرانيا
بالتزامن مع توقيع صفقة دفاعية
متجددة ثم مطالبة بهدنة مطولة
فهل تتحقق بيض في ازمة بسبب
بانتظار رد من مجنون كوريا
الشمالية. المساعدات تتوالى على
اوكرانيا والحرب تستمر. وايران
شوكة عالقة في حلق امريكا. فهل
الروسي محاكاة لعمليات الكترونية
لاطلاق منظومات اسكندر الصاروخية
الدفاع الروسي سنضرب اي وسيلة
تحمل سلاحا الى اوكرانيا ومن اي
على اوكرانيا. موسكو تنفي اي خطط
لاعلان حرب شاملة على اوكرانيا
سلاح نووي بعدما اصبحت عقبة
الحرس الثوري نقطة عالقة امام
فهل تبدأ موسكو حربا ثانية بينما
لم تكمل بعد حربها الاولى
الحرب في اوكرانيا لكن هذا الثمن
ايضا مكلف للمنتقمين انفسهم
الروسية في بيان انه خلال
مناورات عسكرية في كالينين جراد
الموانئ التي اغلقتها البحرية
الروسية. قالت وزارة الدفاع
وسلوفاكيا التي ستوافق مقابل
شروط تدفع موسكو ثمنا باهظا على
بعض دول التكتل نظرا لتداعيات
تلك الخطوة بمعارضة المجر وتخوف
الدول التي ستنضم للناتو. ويا له
من تهديد مرعب. خصوصا ان فنلندا
تفاصيل عن تحركات ومواقع للقوات
الروسية تفاصيل عن المقرات
العسكرية الروسية المتنقلة مكنت
القوات الاوكرانية من تنفيذ
المهني. وتشدد على ضرورة احترام
السيادة بينما كانت قد حذرت
تمتلك حدودا مع روسيا تعادل
ثلاثة اضعاف الجبهة الاوكرانية.
حدودها. بل ان روسيا تهدد بنشر
اسلحتها النووية على الحدود مع
الروسي العسكري بانتهاك اجواء
البلاد بطائرة حربية روسية فان
خبراء عسكريين يتوقعون المزيد من
خطوات استعراض القوة العسكرية
بريطانيا ضمن اهدافه. واتفقت
بريطانيا واليابان على ابرام
الليك الروسي. اوكرانيا تطالب
بصواريخ امريكية على وجه السرعة
المساعدات ثمارها? اليابان في
اتفاق عسكري. قررت الحكومة
ومليارات الدولارات تنهال
لمساعدة كييف. فهل تؤتي هذه
فهل هي اشارة للغرب يا ترى? اما
فيستال فهدنة ثم خيانة فاشتباكات
الخبر بينما تجري روسيا محاكاة
لاطلاق صواريخ تحمل رؤوسا نووية
بمشاركة امريكا بقتل جنرالات روس
في اوكرانيا. لكن لو تأكد هذا
الروسية. بوتين يرسل طائراته
الحربية لارعاب السويد ويحذرها
من عاقبة الانضمام لحلف الناتو.
فهل ترضخ السويد? مفاجأة مدوية